the first thing that presents itself to
you is that three-on-two hearse that's
read to deal with we very seldom see
that power at all right so that's the
first thing that makes you kind of raise
an eyebrow at this but there is another
part of the question that is actually
not unusual at all it's completely
standard which cut is it there's
nobody's hectic where we see this all
the time in fact this is as easy as it
gets really this is screaming at you use
a substitution what substitution is
gonna be the most obvious one now think
I could do this right I could go for a
drop but this 3 over 2 is still going to
present me problems because when I then
do my reverse chain rule I'm gonna have
a derivative of minus 2x then your 2x4
that anything where is he he's not there
what else could I try yeah I want to go
for some trig substitution because if I
have 1 minus sine squared or 1 minus cos
square either of those can be used they
simplify up because of the platic or an
onion so be that the cake I the putt
bless you I'm going to go for any
suggested inside there so let's do it
okay if x equals sine theta that will
help me start to change what's happening
here the function itself but I have two
other things to change at this question
what are they like and up on what the
boundaries number two yeah the actual
variable of integration so let's do both
of those okay
it's pretty easy to do do you so i DX or
do you which is quite is that as a form
that i want it to be to change my
variable of integration it's not I
actually want the DX to be sorry to get
up I want the DX to be on the
denominator I know because I wanted to
cancel with this DX yeah so therefore
I'm just going to divide both sides by
DX with D theta which leave me with this
okay yep that'll take care of the
variable of admission what about the
batteries I'm going to do that when x
equals zero that implies that sine theta
is equal to zero okay so if I take sine
inverse of both of those I'm going to
get clean up yeah and when x equals 1/2
I'm going to say theta will be yep
now just pause for a moment because this
is important notices before this is not
the only solution of this correct we
just did general solution there are
infinitely many solutions okay so why
did I choose what I choose zero there's
an obvious we turned all of Israel
I mean obvious reason is it's the first
solution and it's easy why wouldn't you
choose you if you can avoid it right if
you can if you can use it right but then
when you have a look at the shuttle but
how do I justify that how do I know
that's the value that will do it for me
I've got actually a restriction that's
applied here I have to bring you
restricted in what restriction am I
gonna have on C I actually do this that
the original question also has a
restriction right it has a restriction
on that variable which is X is between
negative 1 and 1
yeah I do notice it's x squared right so
therefore I'm just going to get all the
positive values the negative 1 to 0 part
actually is not that important but I
have to keep in mind so if I have
actually should do the excellent that if
I have this restriction here right that
implies a restriction of negative PI
over 2 to PI over 2 right is that ok
because if I want if you like say oh I
want to try out - seven nine to zero
point seven oh my god well I can find a
theater within this range so I read in
this domain that will give me that
desired value phone
yes because if I put any value outside
of that this is gonna have a number
that's negative underneath the square
root
yeah which I didn't want see it the
square root is apply I could write it as
1 minus x squared times the square root
of 1 minus x squared but um that half
power of it implies it okay
now it is worth learning as well if this
is a restriction on X I actually don't
have any X's just by themselves I have
an x squared so I couldn't say this Zook
really that which actually means for me
if all I need is from naught to 1 if I
wanted to I could say this I could
restrict it restricted even further
which might be nice to be on them but
anyway all that's just like yeah cool
these values all right they might be
important for me when I'm doing
evaluating absolute values so let's now
start to watch it I got all the pieces I
that I need let's do it so I better
change by you oh yes you can yes of
course because 0 is near the edge so as
using that domain so therefore that
implies which is here thank goodness ok
I kind of need that value all right
great we've got some be battery there so
I'm gonna go from naught to PI on 6 okay
what have I got here I need that up I'm
going to change the variable information
so he comes a cos theta D theta DX
yep that's divided by what I got sorry
that's in this query but if I go on I'd
like to go down this is 1 minus sine
squared theta to the power of 3 on 2 and
then there's the DX that was danced
before which now dancers okay now
originally we were thinking about using
a reverse chain rule as a substitution
for minus x squared we go
icky because are they here at this point
I have a minus 2x and I'm like what is
it gonna come from right now it seems
like we've got a similar problem with
cos theta except there is a place that
it comes from because you look here and
there's gonna be some significant
cancelling that happens right
all right let's that's where they stood
still from North supply all the Sikhs
cos theta would be right up
yeah so this is cos squared right and
then you raise it to the power of 3 on 2
so 2 times 3 on 2 is 3
yeah and then I'm integrating with
respect to peanuts
everything's looking good enough you can
actually see this will be even nice not
because this would be 1 on cause sweat
this is sick squared and now the value
this precious get rid of sugar okay so
we'll just finish it off 10 FINA from
multiplying on 6 when you evaluate 103
that's peace okay do you happy with that
keep on keep on thinking about like even
when you see some reader looking power
like that
think about think of tree when you see
that wall minus X square over 4 minus x
squared